[Music]
[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
tonight on piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle knife attacks spike and a
nine-year-old girl is shot dead in her
own home
this is not the time for anyone who
knows who's responsible for this
shooting to remain tight in it
can we restore order in lawless britain
new warnings that bill payers face a
catastrophic winter energy bosses demand
action now and we will speak to one of
them live in the studio a record 1300
migrants reach britain in a single day
how do we change the channel chaos
and meghan markle's podcast finally
launches with a swipe at the royal
family there's a shock and the
patriarchy but will a big money moan
fall on deaf ears
hey
it's me i'm just excited to be myself
and talk and be unfiltered
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends and a big big
welcome to piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy khan a crime is often used as
a political football it's because fear
sells and at heart
law and order is the most fundamental
expectation people have of their
government yes people worry about their
health and their access to basic
services like energy but above all we
want to be kept safe and when those
things begin to break down we rightly
expect solutions well it would be fair
to say that they're breaking down in
britain right now and tonight we want to
ask the question what are the solutions
horrific cases like the fatal stabbing
last week of 87 year old thomas
o'halloran a busker simply out riding
his mobility scooter have made knife
prime suddenly an urgent public concern
again and that's with good reason knife
assaults are up if you look at this they
began rising in 2013 they peaked in 2018
before it seemed like the the situation
was getting under control but those
numbers are now back to 2018 levels and
they are rising first the police
watchdog tells us that victims of
robbery and theft are being failed look
at this just 6.3 percent of robbery
offenses now lead to a charge and that
number falls to 4.1 percent for victims
of theft so
who's going to stop it what is the
answer look at this the uk had 172 000
police officers when the tories took
power in 2010 now austerity slashed
their numbers to just 150 000 by 2019
and whilst boris johnson's government
began to slowly reverse that we still
have now
fewer police in this country than 12
years ago 12 years ago officers numbers
at 160 000 and we're also seeing more
and more shocking videos like this watch
this from chelsea in broad daylight
yesterday
[Music]
that's a man and woman
in broad daylight robbed okay in chelsea
in central london now if britain feels
less safe this isn't scary to say that's
because it is
and i have to say the latest crime to
shock the nation everybody overnight a
nine-year-old girl shot dead in
liverpool olivia pratt gabel was killed
yesterday and her mother and another man
also wounded by gunfire this is a
nine-year-old kid okay as a father i
look at that and i just go
what is becoming of this country police
yes are hunting the gunman this is what
they had to say this afternoon
this is not the time for anyone who
knows who's responsible for this
shooting to remain tight-lipped
it is time for our communities to come
together with us
and make merseyside a place where the
use of guns on our streets is totally
unacceptable
and those who use them are held to
account joining me now is pastor
lorraine jones whose son dwayne simpson
was tragically stabbed to death in
bricks and age just 20 as he did the
honorable thing and tried to save
someone else's life dr victor elisa a
former chief superintendent with the met
police and we'll be hearing from bobby
casanga who spent eight years in prison
for armed robbery and i'm told has
turned his life around and he now runs a
football club in hackney london and
works to keep young people away from
crime welcome everybody i just want to
start lorraine with you
every day
we hear of yet more tragedy
as a mother who lost her son how did you
feel
when you heard about that nine year old
girl last night
i'm still choked up
it's like we're experiencing a horror
which we dreaded
eight years ago
and the
violence has
escalated
out of london across the country and
nine-year-old girl
innocent
shot in the chest
if this isn't a wake-up call
for everybody to come together to deal
with this i don't know what it's going
to take i'm with you and and you know
what i find really frustrating is that
we talk about it bobby welcome to the
show um
i wanted to do this a little bit
differently and i hope you understand
why i know you've turned your life
around but i
people watching this tonight are going
apart from the fact that we can't afford
to survive a lot of us right now
how the hell are we supposed to walk
outside the front door
for fear of what happened to that kid
explain to me
how you ended up being jailed for eight
years for i'm robbie how did you get
into that situation bobby um peer
pressure
lack of of opportunities
no positive role models inequalities
and ultimately beyond all of that is
choice and greed because we can talk
about all these things i've talked about
the lack of equality um lack of
opportunities but there's so many people
who came from the same environment as me
who didn't choose the lifestyle i did so
i like your honesty did you carry a gun
or a knife what did you carry um reese's
curry knives um obviously we've had guns
and that before as well but it wasn't
anything that actually ever used it was
just in participation or the robberies
at the time and it comes down to
deprivation as well thinking that you
need something that you actually don't
you see all these things everyone else
has and you believe you need them but we
didn't have the was naive we didn't have
the knowledge to know that you have to
be patient so that's why when we work
about young people now it's sort of like
teaching them patience and just allowing
and waiting for your time because
everyone that was doing these things
with me
i've got over 20 people who i can say
i've been killed that i knew personally
i've got another over 20 who are doing
life in prison so although i've come out
of that system i've lost many friends
along the way because of that same
system when you looked at that news last
night of that nine year old what was the
first thing that went through your head
absolutely shocking because even in any
form of criminality that you take part
in everyone knows the kind of saying is
that women and kids it's a no-go area so
for someone to go and do that it's
absolutely disgusting when you look at
her look look there in the eyes her son
was stabbed to death you carried a knife
what do you say to her i mean i've met
the lady many many times and we've
spoken a few times and it's the thing
that where
i know now when i was younger i was 14
15 16 it's a lot of that help me out you
talk you're very honest because a lot of
people go inequality or opportunity tell
me if i'm wrong
so many of the kids who end up in gans
gravitate towards that that unit because
the family life isn't great are we right
to blame parents in many instances or
not no because my parents were both
hard-working that they were strict with
me
it all comes down to again choices and
think the fear of missing out parents
told me
be home at 8pm
your friends are hanging out so the
first thing you start doing be
disobedient to your parents began
wanting to hang on a bit later on
because you you're fearing the missing
out of the fun that everyone's having
what did they say when you went to
prison for eight years oh they were
disappointed they were absolutely
disappointed gutted because i was in the
top set at school it wasn't like i was
someone that didn't know what i was
doing i willingly took part in the
activities that i did because i was
greedy and i wanted to
compete and um keep up the joneses
everyone knows had nice things i wanted
to be with them my parents couldn't
really afford it but it was my choice um
victor a former met police
superintendent um
i speak to the police the whole time
peter blexi will be an example and he
says that police men and women
don't have the time anymore to deal with
petty crime because their social workers
their mental health operatives that stat
that crimes under a thousand pounds is
something like just not being
investigated we have heard every plan
and this great desire to reduce the
levels of knife crime gun crime just the
lawlessness that we're talking about
what needs to happen what is the
solution in your mind well i mean you'll
have politicians say that we can't
police our way out of problems but i
think the police can play a really
significant part um you know taking what
we're talking about at the moment the
examples you've given
those people involved whether it's the
offender with the gun where the
nine-year-old girl was tragically shot
whether it's the 58 year old pensioner
who was stabbed those people are
carrying weapons in public places now
how do we incentivize prepare our police
so they can do their work in public
places no stabbing takes place in
private you know and then just having
off oxford street in the premises
you don't expect the police to be in
there but give the police the
opportunity the time to do the work on
the streets it's one of the things that
actually the police are too busy no
disrespect to any of them i think
they're great but they're too busy
filling out forms and ticking boxes on
computers rather walking the beat and
finding out intel and doing the job that
they used to go have we moved policing
away from that common touch and that's
why we're missing out that's the first
question well that is the first question
there is bureaucracy but again you know
i guess we can't put that away because
police officers work independently and
when we want to hold them to account the
only way we can do that is through the
records that they've made and we can't
move away from that but what we can do
is reduce that bureaucracy we can
actually give the police the time to be
able to do some of the work we want them
to do on the street and more importantly
you talk about the other issues you
describe them as social work issues well
there are other public agencies you
should be doing that you know when i was
a cop i've resigned for you know five
years prior to that my officers would go
and deal with someone who had a mental
health problem they will spend two or
three hours
now they're spending six seven hours
because the other public agencies are
not being compelled to contribute to the
work that needs doing you can't blame
the police for that because the police
can't walk away if they get called they
have to go and deal with it lorraine one
of the things that i think really
strongly about you might agree or
disagree is i don't believe
that the the the punishments are strong
enough i look at what happened with acid
they gave life imprisonment to acid and
it is with absolutely a known fact that
those crimes are gonna do we need to be
stronger on people who carry knives and
guns most definitely
my son's killer got 12 years he'd done
half of that he's out enjoying his life
my son's gone for good and we've been
affected for life
the
sentencing needs to be
revised
and modernized
there's no way you can give a higher
sentence for a robbery than for taking
someone's life my son's killer he was
sentenced for
manslaughter because of how the criminal
justice system label
years and
how how it came about that he's killed
my son it's outrageous so that area
definitely needs looking at it's not
acceptable because
more and more are carrying knives and
guns and they're younger
younger the youngest child i was called
by a parent to report an incident at
school was seven years old he brought a
scissors from home a sharp one and
stabbed the other boy in the leg
seven years old
bobby
i agree with lorraine about the criminal
justice system i'm sorry if people don't
like it i think that the sentencing
should be much stronger and and and i
really do believe that as a kid who
perpetrated towards a gang and was out
on the street
did you think hey you could get away
with it did you not consider the
implications and do you today the man
that has turned his life around and runs
this football club in hackney and gets
kids to understand that they need to
change their lives do you think if the
punishments were greater that would help
the situation i think there needs to be
a balance
i think you can't write someone
completely off
there's some people like myself who wear
prison works and there's rehabilitation
i went to prison and decided to get a
degree
while i was in there there's others who
won't learn who come in call back out
again so there needs to be a kind of a
balance maybe someone gets given a very
harsh sentence
and then you monitor them throughout the
sentence are they doing the right
courses are they doing the right things
are they getting a degree but you'd
understand uh you know her son's killer
got 12 years and he's out after six
years absolutely what does that say 100
100 i i get that but i guess um he was
sentenced to manslaughter so the court
judged him to have um committed mansoor
compared to murder
and then he was recalled back after six
years so like what you're saying there
needs to be some restorative justice we
can't just put him in prison and leave
him there they're learning all sorts in
there and they're coming out raving mad
i don't know if this man that has shot
and killed this
child has reoffended there needs to be
restorative justice do you agree with
that quickly victor and i've got to
finish
yeah absolutely it needs to be a balance
but um we need to be very clear for
those people that you know bobby's
talking about those people who will not
respond to the imprisonment then we need
to throw the book at them but we need to
be clear there are some people that are
just so bad prison is the only thing for
them we also need there are people like
bobby who respond you know to a positive
input in prison and come out a very
different person guys fantastic bobby
thank you victor thank you and lorraine
jones thank you very much indeed um now
yesterday i told you that tyson fury
will be joining us on the show today
following the tragic death of his cousin
rico burton who was stabbed to death in
manchester at the weekend tyson got in
touch with the show this morning to say
the situation is so raw he and his
family utterly devastated by the lost
knee didn't feel able to come on tonight
we obviously send tyson and the family
our deep with sympathies and hope very
much to have him back on uncensored soon
when he is ready that's an open open
offer now next on uncensored utility
energy boss bill bullon is here as
exports warn that bills could hit ready
for this
six and a half grand next year and to
that grace blakely and richard tys
standing by to unpack everything that
bullen has to say about rising prices
we're coming right back in three this is
uncensored
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh welcome back to uncensored now in
just a moment i'll talk to the managing
director of utility energy who's been
brave enough to appear here tonight as
rising energy bills continue to keep
misery on struggling families it's
friday that off-gen make that
announcement apparently six and a half
thousand pounds which is going to
destroy people's lives but first jesus
jonas today i'm joined by socialist
author grace blakely and leader of the
reform party richard theis free from
swimming in the ocean somewhere abroad
this morning uh guys on a serious note
um you heard me say about tyson fury
he'd hope to be here tonight to talk
about that tragic stabbing of his cousin
he will be later in the week fingers
crossed it's too raw you saw that first
section um
grace
i i i almost feel like politics is
irrelevant all i hear about is i mean
that that story last night of that
nine-year-old what are the solutions
police apparently with their arms behind
their backs because they're too busy
dealing with mental health issues less
offices on the beat i
honestly you look at it and you despair
don't you
i mean i think if we're looking at this
from a kind of you know more objective
perspective if you look at the
statistics there's a tiny number of
people who show up across all our social
services from looked after children all
sorts of institutional care settings to
the criminal justice system uh to all
parts of the social care system to the
health care system um they end up kind
of being in repeated contact with
authorities over and over again um and
generally they end up being shunted from
one place to another because they're
never given the right support so 25 of
the prison population was at some point
in uh institutional care looked after
children um and 25 of looked after
children end up homeless so these are
the people who are taking up a lot of
these resources have severe mental
health problems drug abuse problems no
real family to support them they need
early intervention and support they're
watching an early intervention so you
know there's lots of proof that if you
provide say kind of therapeutic
particular therapeutic strategies to
kids in these looked after settings in
the criminal justice system at school
very early on it changes everything but
it requires money and that's what people
don't want to do we've seen big cuts to
children's social care to all of our
children social services which is i
think actually a big part of why this is
happening richard um i i actually
genuinely would say that grace
i get the feeling that the criminals
think the police have given up you talk
about the the charge right i get the
feeling that the police are overrun and
can't make the decisions they want to i
gave an example to the to those three
people about acid attacks now you get
life that's dropped do we need to be
stronger or do we need to be educating
is it a combination about what's your
solution my sense is grace is right
about all those stats and that's all
well and good but the reality is
that people who are committing crimes
from the lowest level to the most
horrific uh murder that we've just heard
about is that people don't fear the
consequences there's no respect for law
and order there's no fear that they're
going to be caught we know that the
charge rate has collapsed it's now about
five percent of all crimes so people are
quite clearly saying and you know you
see it from mobs marauding in uh
mcdonald's you see it in people being
mugged on the streets of central video
nobody in chelsea no one fears the
consequences of being caught and if
they're caught that when are they going
to get charged years down the track
during which time they've committed
other crimes it needs a wholesale
rethink and you know it's just not good
enough who's been in charge for 12 years
for the last 12 years a party that's
supposed to be the party of law and
order they're a catastrophe utter utter
failure this is i mean i spoke to
someone the other day who says literally
they're terrified of walking out the
front door here in london it's it's it's
lawless it's getting far worse
and there needs to be a wholesale change
what's actually going to happen is
people got to be charged they've got to
be caught they've got to be charged
instantly and put through the system
instantly and when you get 12 years
that doesn't mean six years jeremy well
it means 12 years i mean that woman you
know i absolutely agree with you right i
also believe that we should be stronger
i also believe people criminals are not
concerned 12 years for her son stabbed
to death and he's out in six years you
won't tell me that that kid would have
been different if he'd been molly
cuddled or told he was going to be right
you saw the raw emotion in that woman
the criminal justice system needs
yanking up doesn't it yeah i mean i
don't think it's about modeling molly
coddling people i think it's about
changing people yeah
all right wrong words but you know what
i mean um obviously case by case you
know you can't go and say uh this
particular case should have been had a
different setting that's to be judged
within the criminal justice system
incidentally by the way we've got a lot
of um
barristers at the moment currently on
strike because that has broken down we
haven't got any funding going into uh
into
so
all of these systems are breaking down
and they are generating this problem
every bit is breaking down and therefore
the criminals have no respect for the
consequences because they know there
won't be anything
there's an issue here which is that you
have kind of two types of criminals
right you have psychopaths you don't
fear the consequences anyway because
they don't fear anything they have no
fear they have no shame whatever they're
always going to bump up against these
systems and they need to be treated
but well it is relatively small but then
you have a lot of other people who just
kind of you know and you see that i have
friends who are teachers who work in
social care um who end up having these
kids very very young just brought into
gangs brought into drugs brought into
all of these things and if we want to
actually change things that's the point
at which we need to be intervening um i
think we all agree in essence but but
again you know what are those solutions
it's across the board maybe stronger
sentences maybe stronger criminal
justice certainly education can i bring
us up so very quickly you said earlier
you've got to get the bobbies back on
the beat on the streets understand their
communities understanding the wrong
they're interested in the writings
yesterday we talked about broken brick
and today we're talking about lawless
britain one wonders what the hell's next
i'm i'm delighted to welcome now uh
ceo um bill bullon who joins us uh three
days before offgem announces they
believe yet another unbelievable rise
they're saying that uh it could be that
our gas electricity bills reach six and
a half thousand pounds bill um i i
appreciate you joining us
um you're here to talk about something
that you've created or are talking about
that's going to help your customers is
that right
yeah
so um today we've uh launched a new
initiative with a partner iceland i
think it's the first of its kind as a
joint um initiative between a high
street supermarket and an energy utility
company which is aimed at you know
helping genuinely helping to cut energy
consumers energy bills
okay um let me try this differently and
i don't mean this in a disrespectful way
because you've come on why don't you
actually concentrate on instead of some
sort of pr exercise the fact is let me
give some facts companies house profits
for your business in march 2021 were sat
down
what
you we spoke only last week about this
issue and you were incorrectly stating a
profit figure for my business 813
million pounds
i if that's our turnover
all i'm saying is right you have four
percent 800 000 customers do you not
think in this current situation you're
honest enough to come on and i
appreciate it do you not think your
customers are crying out for energy
companies to actually try and make their
lives manageable because without
exaggerating it bill there are people
who are gonna go to the wall all across
the united kingdom and you are part of
the issue
look absolutely i you know i understand
that we've got a call center every day
that is taking thousands of calls from
customers who are really struggling to
pay their bills you know don't think for
one minute we have not been passing that
message on to government and to the
regulators but you're still in business
morally it's great but you're still
charging your customers and making
whatever you deny profits for your
business while good honest people are
struggling to pay their bills
jeremy you've got to understand that the
retail operations in the uk energy
market supplying gas and electricity to
residential customers after price
capping came in i've been making no
profit at all yeah okay that is a fact
go and look at companies house look at
the reporting accounts genuinely look at
the reporting accounts with somebody
that understands how to read a set of
financial statements and you will see
that they've not been profitable now
some people further up the chain
are making profits no question about
that of course people pumping gas out of
the north sea are going to be making
much more money yeah but retail
organizations that are controlled by the
price gap are not making profits at the
moment so are you saying that you
haven't made any profit whatsoever
recently you're you know ebitda nothing
no the bottom line is negatively nothing
you cannot dispute anything
the evidence is there guys i'm not you
know i wouldn't be saying
you've not you've not given a dividend
at all recently are you saying that
correct several years many years
basically
i remember the last time we paid the
dividend the retail suppliers like
bill's company they're not making any
money for that's not true of all of hang
on that is definitely not true 30 of
them went bust last year the profits the
extreme profits are being made by the
producers the of of energy
the wind farms uh the the gas companies
the power plant but his companies and
companies are still in business
so we've got to provide the service okay
the majority of them are making if any
margin at all the mega it's the producer
of it the truth is though this is much
bigger so
it is true many of the big five energy
companies the big six depending on how
you want to categorize it all of them
made fairly good profits
let's be perfectly honest bill you've
stuck your head above the parapet and
for that i absolutely respect you and we
talk about the big companies like bp and
shell who are making all the money and
maybe it's wrong to pile on to you
because you're a retailer but i'm going
to ask you something just as a an
everyday person right across the united
kingdom off gem on friday might announce
it at six and a half grand
do you understand that even being
associated with the business you're
going to be tainted do you understand to
politicians to energy companies i'm not
bothered about oh shell last year didn't
make any money it is utterly disgusting
and disgraceful for for massive
companies in energy to to pump out
profits of 20 billion right take massive
dividends and expect everyday people who
i did this is what i want to say they
are not going to be able to pay they're
not you're absolutely right jeremy
i completely understand that people
aren't going to be able to pay and
that's one of the reasons why we've said
to you know the government and to the
regulator you know we really cannot go
ahead with this announcement on friday
right that's our
we'll get to a point on friday we're
expecting a price increase to about
three and a half thousand pounds to put
that in perspective that's about a third
of the national pension does it morally
can i ask you a question
because i said you're good enough to
come on does it morally sit badly with
you honest question does it morally
upset that you know i you know i've been
arguing this and i'm continuing to argue
i'm trying to argue it now that we need
to have a price freeze because we cannot
keep expecting i mean ultimately if
you're energy customers of any sort not
just residential customers but business
if you're going to be regulating the
company this heavily if you're really if
you're really not making any profit
right which means that you know it's
gonna be hard for you to invest why are
these private companies to begin with
you know the whole reason that these
were supposed to be privatized was so
that they would have all this profit
that would go back into investment it
would give us a more efficient system
that's not happening
we're
we're in a global energy war everybody's
scrabbling for energy this is going to
last three to five years and the
government needs to adopt a warlike
wartime solution nobody is thinking and
i'm gonna be releasing on thursday a big
serious plan this is way bigger way more
terrifying than anybody realizes can i
just deal with it now can i just ask all
three of you do you all share my horror
uh publicly for for people who are
really struggling when they hear that
shell and bp have 20 billion pounds with
a profit do you understand that the
people of the united kingdom will go
well hold on a minute you're making
those profits and our bills are going up
and we're struggling and the fat cats
are getting richer and i'm not usually
like this but why doesn't anybody listen
because there's a vacuum of leadership
because they're trying to become find a
new prime minister we've got no
government and we've got the greatest
gravest economic and energy crisis any
of us have ever seen in our lifetimes
and it's only going to get worse
breakdown continues as well very quickly
who's to blame well how do we
decarbonize 10 20 years ago we wouldn't
be dependent on poor russia what an
authoritarian regime and we wouldn't be
facing the steep energy crisis bill
final word from you really appreciate
you being on what do you say pal
as i've said already we need to this
problem has been accelerating away we've
got this vacuum of leadership at the
moment which is the worst time in the
world for it to happen but we now need
to just announce a freeze in the price
gap and and deal with this problem you
know
by getting ahead of it and stop chasing
it that that's absolutely clear in my
mind what we need to do bill really
appreciate it pal sorry if i misquoted i
appreciate you being on
youtube thank you to richard tice and
thank you to grace blakely very very
feisty right next uncensored grace
shouldn't stay for this almost 1
300 migrants across the english channel
in small boats yesterday setting another
appalling new record the question
everyone's asking and they've been
asking it for months is what are we
gonna do about it we'll discuss that
next we're coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now almost 1
300 migrants crossed the channel in
small boats on monday setting another
unwanted record for crossings in a
single day these are the latest pictures
from dover as yet more people undertake
the perilous journey to britain more
than 22 000 have done so this year
that's almost double last year's figures
now the number of migrants sent to
rwanda on the government's headline
grabbing deterrent policy is so far a
big
zero but with the royal navy backing out
of patrols france of course unwilling or
unable to stem the tide and people
smugglers clearly undaunted how do we
take back control of britain's borders
this is one of the most important things
to people apart from everything else
that's going on joining me now is former
international border control advisor
henry bolton and director of policy and
advocacy at the freedom from tortoise
steve crawshaw thank you both for
joining me henry
a bit like lawless britain
and there's a connection the migrant
problem is something that we see and
hear about daily right
we hear that you know france you know
take more we see these people being
smuggled in boats some of them losing
their lives we seem incapable incapable
as a nation of getting it right what
needs to be done i think the first thing
is we need to recognize that there is a
lack of knowledge and expertise in the
home office and across government to be
able to come up with an appropriate
solution what we have is government here
that is trying to hit headline
issues it's not actually trying to
deliver a positive operational effect on
the ground what needs to happen is there
needs to be a full strategic framework
created across government all of the
different agencies that need to be clear
objectives strategic objectives and
clear unity of effort there's not the
leadership there to do it first off
that needs to include diplomatic efforts
to enter
british tactical officers and
intelligence officers on the ground
along those routes to work with local
law enforcement it's been done 2001 to
2006 we were doing it i was involved in
it uh in the balkans we went out there
with local law enforcement using uk
intelligence and we kicked indoors
literally kicked indoors british
officers working with local law
enforcement and we used the foreign aid
budget to fund that so that's the
disruption let's interrupt that flow
because once these people and if you
look at migrants they're all not just
migrants they are a commodity for the
criminal advocacy
as well absolutely and you get them to
the the
north french
the channel coast and they will find a
way across there's no real way back for
them and there are all sorts of things
that you've got to unpack on the way
such as why we've got an increase in the
number of albanians and so on and the
feed through in that sense to organize
crime back here in the uk but we've got
narcotics coming across the channel as
well there's an explosion in cocaine and
opiates in the uk that's related to this
too
back here we've got a mess in the
channel we've got eight different
government agencies with patrol boats in
the channel compare that to the u.s
coast guard one agency it
are we i haven't got a lot of time and
i'd love to have more steve i'll bring
you in um
this is one of the things that
frustrates british people so much and
anybody who seems to say you know this
is distract but it's dreadful and it
should change they're accused of not
understanding there are people who
suffer but it would be fair to say as
well this is a good old place to come
blighty isn't it to be fair
it's a place which is certainly better
from where they're fleeing from they're
fleeing from syria from
afghanistan of them are fleeing from
france
why don't they stay in france why is it
great britain
same argument of course could be made
absolutely anyway the french could say
they shouldn't be staying here they
should be in germany the germans could
say they should be in greece but do you
understand people watching this people
always stay fairly close so with ukraine
now many many millions are in poland
many of them will ever come here but far
more in germany than our are here less
than in poland and that's what i think
we need to have that sense of all
sharing that responsibility and my
colleague for example freedom from
torture he was a torture survivor
himself arrived in his country in what
this government called illegally but in
other words he didn't have the visa
before arriving you know just a couple
of years ago he received his mbe for the
queen for the amazing things he's done
for this country i get and that's the
way around i get that and change that
mind i absolutely agree and i just a
couple of things i'd like to add i think
that that all everybody joining in is
never going to work since we left the
european union i think we're being
punished whether people like that
opinion or not but but
there are genuine people this country
proved during the ukraine crisis what it
could do but i repeat the question
nobody's answered my question do you
understand british people's frustration
because some of these people okay
are taking advantage do you agree with
that i underst i i i understand the
perception of that is very strong i also
understand it was interesting hearing
henry's talking about the government
getting the headlines i think that's
right they want that perception of that
the reality is that when things have
gone through the overwhelming majority
are in fact found to be genuine asylum
seekers the kind of people who come
through the doors from torture having
suffered so much
at the moment the burden of proof is so
poor
in terms of proving that you or even
providing any evidence whatsoever that
you might basically all you have to do
is say i will be persecuted if i go back
and that's a lot of the case now we've
got the albanians you know they are the
largest single nationality at the moment
crossing now the fact is i was i was an
advisor to the albanian prime minister's
office uh i four organized crime on the
ground in that area of the balkans in
albania northern macedonia and kosovo
and the fact is that there is no risk in
albania there's there is surely an
economic problem but these people are
allowed into the european union
on a 90 90 days without a visa that gets
them to the north french coast then
they've got to make the job okay let me
let's take this great majority of people
who've taken very long very very
different you keep saying the great
majority of people there are plenty of
examples of people who are coming to
this country tearing up whatever paper
they have and disappearing i want to ask
you this
nobody's answered this in the middle of
this cost of living crisis in the middle
of lawless britain the men and women up
and down this country who go
why why is england so attractive because
we do so much should we not whether this
is met with completely do you understand
people thinking well actually i should
be getting more because i've been here
all my life i've paid in and it's
frustrating on a human level i
understand that but i also understand
that when people meet the people who've
come they go well
you deserve and you deserve when it's
turned into individuals the government
is great to make it nothing about the
government's first living
people the government's first duties is
to its own people of course i understand
it and i have been trying for three
years to get into the home office to
talk to them about how to solve this
i've helped 14 countries to solve
similar problems i can't speak to my own
government although they were paying me
when i was helping other governments so
there is a real problem here yes we have
to solve it with a humanitarian mind i
agree no we cannot turn away people who
are absolutely at risk
but the fact is that we have got a large
proportion of the people coming across
the channel not only in boats but as we
now know in the back of trucks as well
who are quite frankly economic migrants
who have traveled through the european
union because we are an attractive
destination if you were to try to stop
for example tourists going to a
particular destination what you would
try to do is make the journey there less
attractive the destination that they get
exactly and try to close down the people
who are moving than the travel agency i
completely agree final word steve i get
where henry's come from i also get i do
think i try and do it from the angle of
what people are thinking i do think we
should obviously look after people who
come from war-torn zones as we've proven
but you have not acknowledged what he
and i have said there are a lot of
economic migrants who make it to this
country which is more attractive than
anywhere else but i did say that the
overwhelming majority of those who try
who seek asylum are actually getting it
so the public narrative that the
government gives you're absolutely right
the polling shows clearly britain's want
to help those who have been through
terrible things but the way the
government spins it and it really is
spin it simply absolutely goes against
the reality spins it as though everyone
is trying to game the system and they
create the narrative day after day month
off i i think we're going too easy
we're too willing to grant asylum i
don't think any of my colleagues who
have been through sometimes for years
waiting for decisions can i can i just
think any of them could possibly agree
with that well listen and that's and
with the greatest respect that's what a
democracy and debate is about but yet
again as i said at the beginning of the
show we all know there's a problem what
is the damn solution is it what you say
is it what you say make your minds up at
home right next to them censor thank you
henry uh thank you very much steve after
almost two years an 18 million quid
beat excited be excited my friends
meghan markle releases her first podcast
on spotify yippee our meg takes another
swipe at the royal family and complains
about being called ambitious has she
been treated unfairly yeah i can't wait
for this we're back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh welcome back so note to self try and
be balanced here we go now privacy
loving harry and megan have kept a
remarkably low profile since eloping to
california to escape the media spotlight
that is of course if you excuse the book
deals the silicon valley startups the
100 million dollar deal with netflix and
the regular trips to europe we've barely
seen or heard from them at all until now
because my friends are mere 20 months
since pocketing 18 million quid from
spotify yeah i know you can't pay your
bills the first episode of megan's not
at all anticipated podcast series
archetypes was released today and in a
rare moment of introspection megan says
that marrying prince harry made her feel
the negative connotation of the word
ambition
whatever that means she also compares
notes on her shared roots with tennis
star serena williams if you must have a
listen
so i don't
ever remember
personally feeling the negative
connotation behind the word ambitious
until i started dating my now husband
and um
apparently ambition is a
terrible terrible thing
for a woman that is according to some
this morning i was saying to harry i
said do you remember one of those i'm
the one for the rest i was about to say
when they said harry's girl is straight
out of compton i was like are they
talking about serena
[Laughter]
i'm not from you know
i'm not from compton i've never lived in
compton my mom doesn't live in compton
but by the way what's wrong with compton
my girl serena's from there
i know wait wait a minute
now to discuss this i'm joined by
playwright and author bonnie gurin
socialite and aristocat lady victoria
harvey let's start in california uh
victoria welcome to the show um is this
a dig uh to the royal family saying
marrying harry what was it created
negative connotations of her ambition
what does she mean
i mean yes she is definitely playing
that card again and opening up that door
again to possibly be talking more about
the royal family and her personal
experiences i think she just likes to
blame other people and it's this whole
sort of woke victim
playing card that she does a lot
um which she then puts onto
you know serena during this and um
i don't know i find that the whole
interview she's almost trying to mirror
oprah
in certain ways the way she talks to her
it's a little condescending especially
when she talks about her roots um
bonnie um i know you're going to
disagree violently is this just it's all
about victimhood this is what i thought
right i absolutely supported them in
saying i don't want to be in the media
spotlight i want to go and live my life
but when you land and you sign a 118
million dollar deal or whatever i didn't
see lucky
i mean that's incredible you should be
celebrating this why are you sitting
here complaining about it
you're not even letting me speak it
might be a good thing but she's making
money from the very thing that she said
forced her out of this country and then
she's using the royal family to slag
them off to make the money and the
people appreciate it
if we don't listen to it we won't hear
it will we you're promoting her
very true point okay
yeah very true do you think she's been
unfairly treated by the royal family uh
i don't know
i have no idea can i say something like
that i have no idea and you don't know
do you think she had a plan all along
bonnie a plan to do what
tate prince harry from the arms of the
royal family rise from being a zed list
celebrity to a lot more do you think she
planned the whole thing in her head well
how insulting to harry i'm just a very
good person i mean how insulting i mean
seriously this is a grown man he fell in
love with her obviously you fell in love
with your wife i did okay there you go
but you don't think there's anything
about meg and megan that is and i think
a lot of people in this country feel
this they feel i actually think people
in this country were very excited and
then they felt let down
let down by them both do you know no i
don't feel it i mean first of all she's
a grown woman
uh she was from she's a californian and
lady victoria knows california she acted
exactly as she should act so you're not
surprised by what happened what what
happened in terms of the fact that they
quit the royal family went to america
well she's a grown-up
and they should have actually allowed
her to do her thing and as you said
she was a very good thing
on paper and in fact for this country
and for the royal family it was a
question i i listen the beauty of life
is i don't actually agree with that at
all but there you go lady victoria what
do you say is it all about victimhood
what's going on
um i i no i mean like i kind of agree
with bonnie that i think i mean i think
it was a quite a calculated move with
megan i think she you know set her
sights on harry from the beginning he
was very vulnerable
um
you know from his childhood and and and
she she latched on to that jump in
youtube victoria
with respect with respect
we do know everything about harry you
know because he's been a public figure
but how can we sit here and psycho
analyze this guy i mean that's wrong
that's literally but i i just thought i
i think that that is the way he comes
across
but that's not the same thing is for us
to know we can't do that to people
but her personality is very overpowering
come on don't do that to him this guy is
a girl he looks like what are you doing
since he's been with her he was a proper
man all right let's make it more simple
i haven't got a lot of time i'd love to
have more bonnie do you understand
people in this country's frustration
with meghan markle because there is huge
frustration
they'd be frustrated they'd be glad she
wasn't french
that's not they'd be really frustrated
no i think there is an element of in
this country who don't actually like
foreigners
even though even though the royal family
is german
completely agree final word from you
victoria what do you say i haven't got
long
the final thing that i want to say about
her podcast
good well that about sums it up uh i
won't be listening you might listen
everybody everybody has an opinion about
harry and megan and they are entitled
that opinion thank you to bonnie thank
you to lady victoria uh will i be
watching or listening to a podcast no
will you
i don't listen to anybody's podcast
brilliant i love her right that is it
from me
what a happy lady you are that's it from
me don't forget what piers always says
whatever you're up to make sure you keep
it uncensored that's it for tonight see
you
[Music]
soon i'm tom newton-dunn and this is
talk tv the most memorable moment in my
career without sounding completely
conceited it has to be interviewing
president trump in the open office in
the white house particularly the little
red button he had on his desk i have no
idea what he did is he went on one of
the more moves he's going to launch a
nuclear strike on north korea or open up
a shark pit that i'd then fall into
turned out he pressed it right at the
end of the interview and he walked a
butler with a tray and carrying a dark
hood
here's the diet coke
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams police
in liverpool have described how a gunman
forced his way into the house of
nine-year-old olivia pratt corbell
before blindly firing and shooting her
dead and injuring her mother the shooter
had chased another 35 year old man into
the house who was picked up by friends
and taken to hospital while olivia lay
dying
the search for student nurse swami
davies is over and she's been found
alive and well in hampshire the 24 year
old had been missing for six weeks the
metropolitan police have thanked the
public for reporting more than 100
sightings of her
and the battle of birmingham as tory
leadership hopefuls liz trust and rishi
sunak have once again faced off this
time for the times radio hustings where
warnings of 18 inflation were top of the
agenda that's all for now we'll have
more after the talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you